نوه مشاهدينا لهذا الخبر العاجل اذا اعلان
كتائب القسام قصف تلبيب برشقه صاروخيه ردا
كما تقول على المجازر الصهيونيه بحق
المدنيين ومراسل الجزيره يشير ل صفارات
ايضا انذار تدوي في تل ابيب الكبرى ونحو
20 مدينه ونتابع ايضا هذه الصور واعتراضات
صاروخيه في سماء
تلبيب
وا ت ما
[تصفيق]
ز
[موسيقى]
w
ز
[موسيقى]
لازلنا نتابع ايضا هذه الصور التي وصلتنا
قبل قليل من تل ابيب من التفاصيل معنا من
رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري
وليد كيف تتابع معنا اذا هذه الصور و هذه
ربما رساله جديده من المقاومه لاسرائيل
والمقاومه قالت بان هذا ياتي ردا على
المذابح التي تواصلها الجيش الاسرائيلي في
قطاع غزه
الاسرائيليون فهموا هذه الرساله على انها
تعكس قدره باقيه لدى المقامه المقاومه
وتحديدا كتائب القسام لقصف عمق اسرائيل
الصواريخ التي اطلقت استهدفت منطقه واسعه
هي منطقه ما تعرف بجوج دان او تلبيب
الكبرى ومنطقه السحل السهل الساحلي
الجنوبي اكثر من 20 بلده ومدينه بالاضافه
لتل ابيب الكبرى دوت فيها صافرات الانذار
دفعه واحده المعلومات الاوليه تحدثت عن
انه كان هناك اعتراض لثلاثه صواريخ في
اجواء تل ابيب باقي المناطق لم يرد بعد
تفاصيل حولها لكن هذا اعتبر تطورا وفق ما
نقله مراسلون عسكريون اسرائيليون عن الجيش
تطورا جديدا بعد ان كان التقديرات الامنيه
الاسرائيليه بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه قد
فقدت قدرتها على اطلاق الصواريخ وانها
محصوره فقط باطلاق صواريخ لمدي قصيره مثل
منطقه غلاف غزه لكن استهداف منطقه تل ابيب
وهذه المره الثانيه منذ بدايه هذه هذا
العام كان هناك في راس السنه تماما مع
دخول السنه الجديده سنه عام 24 اطلاقا
مشابها واعتبر انه كان واسعا جدا وهذه
المره ايضا يعتبر هذا الاطلاق واسع وياتي
في وقت كان فيه نتنياهو ووزير دفاعه جلنت
يقدمان
احاطه امنيه عسكريه ل نواب كتله حزب
الليكود ويؤكدون على
مسامعهم بان هذا اليوم يؤكدون على ان
الحرب لا تقترب من نهايتها وانها مستمره
سواء في الشمال او في الجنوب في اشاره
لقطاع غزه وفي اشاره للبنان وانها ستستغرق
اشهرا عديده اخرى هذا التصريح جاء في وقت
كانت قد تردد فيه بان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه طالب
نتنياهو وقبل وصوله بلينكن طالب نتنياهو
بضروره الانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه من
الحرب وهي مرحله الانسحاب من داخل المناطق
الماهوله والمسكون في قطاع غزه
ومضاعفه ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه مع فتح
معبر بيت حنون ايرز ايضا لادخالها وليس
الاكتفاء برفح ومنطقه كرم ابو سالم وذكي
تصل الى المواطنين الفلسطينيين في شمالي
القطاع لكن ما جرى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
ذهب خلال اليومين الاخيرين الى القيام بما
يشبه عمليه اعاده انتشار وابقى قواته على
تخوم هذه الاحياء المدمره والمقتضى بجثث
الضحايا ولم يفعل ذلك في منطقه جنوب قطاع
غزاله بل ضاعف من قصفه على الوسطى الاقليم
الوسطى دير البلح ومخيماتها وكذلك
منطقه خان يونس وطال القصف من جديد منطقه
رفح وهي المناطق التي كان يقول
للفلسطينيين بانها ستكون امنه وان يلجوا
اليها كما ان نقطه الخلاف الاخرى بين
الامريكيين الاسرائيليين بهذا الخصوص
تتعلق بطلب امريكي
بضروره ان تسمح اسرائيل للمواطنين
الفلسطينيين الذين نزحوا وهجروا قصرا عن
منطقه شمال قطاع غزه الى الجنوب بالعوده
الى احيائهم والى منازلهم وما تبقى منها
هذا التطور الذي حصل هذه الليله بهذه
الدفعه من الصواريخ اشار من وجهه النظر
الاسرائيليه بان المقاومه ورغم كل ضراوه
الحرب وعمليات القصف الاسرائيليه والسيط
الاسرائيليه الجويه والى حد ما البريه
والبحريه ووجود قوات اسرائيليه بريه على
نطاق واسع في الجنوب وكذلك في الشمال هي
ما زالت قادره على اطلاق الصواريخ وهو
مؤشر على ان قدرتها في اطلاق الصواريخ هي
مساله تشير الى انها ما زالت قادره على
خوض القتال مع القوات الاسرائيليه هذه
القوات الاسرائيليه تشغل تحديدا في منطقه
خان يونس قوات من النخبه من من شلدا ومن
سياره متكال وكذلك من شياته 13 وهي جميعها
نخب لقوات سلاح الجو ولقوات البحريه
ولقوات ايضا نخبه النخبه دوريه رئاسه
الاركان المعروفه بسياره متكال التي عاده
ما تنشط خلف الحدود في عمليه خاصه ومميزه
هذه المره معركتهم هي في منطقه خان يونس
تحديدا قصف كثيف كان وقتال ضار لكن جاءت
اطلاق الصواريخ الذي استهدف منطقه تلبيب
نم الكبرى وكامل منطقه الساحل السهل
الساحل الجنوبي نحو اكثر من 20 بلده
ومدينه ايضا ليشير الى ان المقاومه